hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round three it's Game Magnus
Carlsen versus Vishwanathan Anand
current world chess champion versus
former world chess champion the two
rivals meet again and it's really really
an intense game sorry about not covering
it yesterday it was a very late when the
game ended and I had to go out for a
beer there I'm just gonna put it out
there but it's really an interesting him
and it follows a lot of interesting
games that have been played so let's
just check it out we do have some
footage so let's check out the doors
first as well as something is lagging in
my in my PC so hopefully it will it will
go smoothly so here we have a nice photo
of Anand he's just you know observing
some not enough for a video observing
some other players enjoying enjoying the
views and there you have it it lags a
bit but I have no idea why all the other
videos are pretty normal so there we
have it a very nice footage of Anand
just you know chilling enjoying his
position and then we have a nice photo
of Magnus here just you know also
enjoying his position thinking about
what to do and here lastly we have yet
another nice footage of Anand there
habit extreme high quality a compliments
of the green tea chest classic video
team so I do hope you enjoyed that
I certainly have I always enjoy some
high quality footage now let's check out
the game Coulson has the white pieces he
started his first two games with two
wins with the black pieces now he gets
the white pieces against around so c4
cousin goes for the English opening and
the so far Crossin had excellent success
with the English with E 5 by Anand with
g3 preparing turf in cattle delights
were Bishop Knight to f6 and Knight to
c3 Bishop to b4 by Anand and here cross
and goes
efore and this is the same line as cross
and played against Caruana in the World
Chess Championship match in London in
2018 it was the the 13th game or the
first game of the rapid section where
the game continued with castles Khurana
castle but here honor prepares a
different line he plays a bunch of
characters on c3 which deviates from the
line that Causton won against
in the water championship match d
captures on c3 and now of course you
cannot capture on e4 it's a pretty
similar idea as in the rule opus where
black who goes for this idea sorry about
that it didn't even realize the Queen
will just go for the five point and the
knight on e4 you'll have to move the
night and then you capture this with
Czech and black doesn't really have
anything to show for this so after D
captures on c3 with d6 by Anand and now
comes f3 strengthening the e4 pawn and
here there is another game where Bishop
to e6 was played across and plated
against petrov in the 2018 world rapid
championship in sankt-petersburg and he
run and doesn't go for Bishop to e6 like
petrov did Alan goes for a5 and it's the
same game that happened between Peter
Svidler and the beginning to machines
Tomashevsky in the Bundesliga 2018
thomashefsky went for this a5 line
against Svidler but ok nice to h3 and
here is where we once again deviate
thomashefsky played night to a6 against
hitler and that game ended in a draw but
he runnin goes for a4 so it seems aren't
out prepared Carlsen for this game this
is a new move and well we have a new
game now
Crossing goes 92 f2 we have push up to
e6 now and here comes Bishop to d3 just
developing the bishop Knight bTW 7 by
Anand and here comes Queen to e2 and
here Anand already gives calls and some
advantage in the in the opening the
correct line is nice to see five and now
if course and tries to force F for like
he did in the game now you just capture
here and after Queen captures he
captures on f/4g captures and the Knight
to g4 hoping to exchange yet another
piece black will do will do well here
but here on plate
c6 and it seems to be a bit too slow
cross and immediately advances his f4
pawn and now we have night the b6 now
with a double attack against the c4 pawn
but the point is protected twice so
there's no problems there Bishop to e3
and now comes c5 just closing the center
with further control of the d4 square we
have queenside castle by Carson and
comes Queen to e7 aren't still keeping
his options of castling open but it is
very unlikely that he will Castle
kingside as f5g 4g5 would be pretty
pretty scary from blacks perspective
with f5 by Carson Bishop to d7 and now
comes g4 so Carlsen already starts to
advance response on the kingside h6
preventing g5 but cousin just pushes h4
so g5 is coming and Anand Castle
queenside he's not interested in keeping
his king in the center or the Queen's
King side g5 by Carlson and knight back
to EA and here just Bishop to d2 we have
h5 % g 5h capture some g5 and Knights
the c7 now with Knight to g4
Coulson just keeps increasing the
pressure and here rook D to g8 rook to H
to cross and now hopes to double up
rooks on the H file Queen to effaith and
now just rug D to H 1 Carson is hoping
that Ireland will capture on h2 so
Carson would keep his control of the H
file and of course on and his hoping
Carlson will capture and exchange
everything along the H file which calls
and of course isn't interested in doing
King to b8 and just improves the
position of his King and now b4 as the
the the idea in the king side is in the
center is pretty closed Crossin has the
control of the H file on the on the King
side and now it's time to transfer the
game over to the Queen side so it seems
ever since the the games by alpha 0 were
published it seems that every high level
game is played on both King side and
Queen side and here if you don't react
to this if you play something like curl
let's say f6 then a3 just cements this
structure on the Queen side and well
white will keep his control on the King
side let's say captures captures now
white would control the central white
would also control the Queen side and
the white would have complete control of
the H file therefore control of the King
side so Anand isn't interested in this
he plays a captures sorry cap person b3
I am bass on it captures on b3 and now
Knight to c8 just waiting to see what
Carson will do kink the b2 and now Queen
to d8 and here look to h7 grabbing more
space on the King side so not really a
threat or anything it is just
a nice bone bone in in the in the throat
so Luke captures on h7 Anand decides to
trade one per rooks rook captures on h7
and not rook to e8 hoping to trade off
yet another pair and now just Queen to
h2 we have rook captures Queen captures
on and is now successful in trading of
the rooks and now Queen to f8 just
defending the g7 pawn and asking Carson
what do you want to do here the material
on the board is completely equal across
and still has the bishop pair but unless
he is able to activate the bishop pair
there's no way to take advantage of the
bishop pair Knights the III by Carlson
and the now comes Knight to e7 we have
King to see to khasinau wants to bring
his King over to the Kings side we have
Queen to g8 and now just Queen back to
h4 and Queen back to f8 and here cross
and goes King to d1 so here if you
remember Carson's game against young
Vince were and Carson was doing all of
those King moves ivanson was spending a
lot of time but it's not the case here
Anand is not puzzled by cousins King
moves and he keeps playing even faster
than Carlsen Knight to c6 by Anand and
now Queen back to h7 and repeats Knight
to e7
he keeps control of the g8 square if he
wants to kick away cousins Queen with
King to g8 as the the Queen trade
wouldn't really be favorable for Carlsen
king te to nakum's knight back to c8 and
King to f2 knight back to e7 on repeats
and now Bishop to e2 what's Carson's
idea well you will just have to wait and
see Queen to g8 again on enforces call
since Queen back we have Queen 2 8 1 and
now g6 hoping Carson will will either
push or or capture on g6
as that would pretty much take care of
all the tension on the King side
Queen to h6 by Carlsen and now Knight
back to 8 we have f6 finally in the now
Knight comes to c6 and here Carson goes
B for now everything is settled in the
center everything is settled on the King
side now crossing once again transfers
the game to the Queen side hoping that
Island captures that Carlsen can under
ball his pawns push b5 and grab even
more space on the Queen side
unand ignores this we have night the sea
seven and now comes B captors on c5 d
captors on c5 now the D file isn't open
and well whoever gets to use it will be
very happy Knights the d5 by Carlson
again hoping if Ireland captures then he
will once again undable his pawn
structure Knight the e6 by Anand
and here comes Bishop to e3 just keeping
everything in check
Carlson's bishop pair is doing good work
now keeping control of all the points
and all the squares in the center and on
ins Knights are not yet able to activate
King to a7 by Anand and now Bishop to g4
and here the idea is if Carson is able
to capture the night here he will remove
the defender of the c5 pawn hopefully
capture the pawn then and proceeded that
way
Anand of course doesn't allow it he
protected to the pawn b6 and here Knight
to c7 a very sneaky move by crossing
here if you capture the night then cross
and captures the bishop on d7 and now
only good move his Queen to eight
defending the knight and now Queen to g7
again Black has two weaknesses you will
not be able to defend if 98 to defending
the pawn then Queen to f8 the White
Queen infiltrates and it will be very
hard for black to hold this position
Anand isn't interested in this honor
immediately goes Queen to c7 he wants to
kick away the night and now comes Knight
the b5 check we have King to b8 and now
Knight back to d6 attacking the Queen
and the f7 pawn so Anand has to defend
it we have Queen to g8 and now that the
night is here we have Queen to h1 here
you can see this very nice idea of Queen
d1 Queen a for Queen a6 and Queen b7
checkmate of course that's a lot of
moves on and we'll also play something
but it is a nice trajectory for the
White Queen to follow if if possible so
Queen to f8 on an immediately wants to
get rid of this Knight Queen to d1
defending the knight here and also
preparing night the b5 we have night C
to d8 now the bishop controls the a
Foursquare and here Carlsen closes at
night b5 now definitely preparing Queen
to a4
bush of the c6 putting pressure on the
e4 pawn and now just kink the g1
King to g1 a very strong move by
and preparing a very strong maneuver but
it's very hard to spot it here night the
c7 hoping to get a favorable of trade on
b5 and here there is only one good move
that allows caution to push for
advantage so take you know consider this
position think you're playing with the
white pieces and try to figure out how
to continue this position with white
I'll give you a couple of seconds it's a
really strong idea so you take even even
a minute if you feel like or half an
hour if you have for those of you that
that were able to do it congratulations
it's really a wonderful Bishop maneuver
also says they recommended it so
congratulations sorry about that if you
found it in photos if you just wanna
enjoy the show Bishop to f2 now you see
the idea behind cross and scheme to g1
making room for the bishop here the
bishop is now coming to g3 and the e5
point is very weak Anand continues nice
to b7 and now comes Bishop to g3
attacking the pawn here and here's the
problem if you play something like Queen
e8 defending the pawn then you get
Knight d6 and after captures captures
now both the Queen and the bishop or
attacking the pawn Bishop captures on e5
is here and blacks position will fall
apart so after Bishop to g3 on and
doesn't allow Knight b6 he captures on
b5 we have Bishop captures on b5 C
capture son b5 and now Queen to d6
defending the pawn and here is the
critical moment of the game once again
feel free to pause the video here and
try to imagine how you would continue
this position with the white pieces I'll
give you a couple of seconds as usual
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are just just a just
a real mastermind of chess as this is a
really really difficult position and for
those who just won't enjoy the show the
idea is king to f1 this is a cross and
missed this idea but it's really really
complicated and it's really hard to spot
why the line cousin plate isn't just as
good but the fraud the thing is after
King to f1 Queen captures Bishop
captures and now Knight captures on d5
now you capture an e5 with Czech
kink the c8 and now you go Bishop to e2
you force them
to move the bishop protects the c3 pawn
and now after the knight retreats now
you go Bishop to g4 check King to d8 and
now Bishop captures on c7 King captures
on c7 and now II five and after black
makes a move let's say King to b8 you
don't want to allow six and f7 black ink
has to keep an eye on the pawns now
Bishop to f3 you threaten the night and
now the knight can't go here or the here
because the King is there you have to go
Knight a5 and now you push east 6 F
captures on e6 and after Bishop 34
you're gonna eliminate the g6 pawn
you're gonna be left with two connected
pass points on the King side and this
will be winning so this was the wind
idea for white and Carlsen played Queen
to e2 and this allowed an informant to
go for a brilliant defensive line I
don't play nice the e6 now threatening
to capture the g5 pawn and if Carlsen
doesn't want to allow this if he still
wants to keep the bishop pair he will
have to lose material so here Carlson
doesn't find any way to continue and
there really isn't any he plays a little
characters on e6 he has to get rid of
his strong bishop we have Queen captures
on e6 and now Queen to h2 and it's still
a very strong idea you're gonna capture
this some back rank ideas do become
possible but Anand calculates everything
precisely we have Queen to g4 now
pinning the bishop also preparing to
capture on g5 we have King to f2
unpinning but just Queen captures on e4
with Bishop captures on e5 with check
King to c8 and now comes Queen to h3
with check King to d8 and now Queen to a
trade by Carlsen we have King to b7 and
here you have to try and figure out how
to continue this but there is no way for
example a nice line is Queen to b8 just
threatening Queen c7 check fall by Queen
to e7 checkmate but it doesn't work
after King to e6 you you run out of
ideas for example Queen eh check you
will go King to f5 and now after Queen
captures on f7 now the King is very
close to the White King you can just go
Queen C to check King III now you can
check the King here can give to Queen C
to check and you have a perpetual
there's no way for white to get rid of
all the checks
so after hinted
vii cousin saw that there's no way for
him to continue the attack he went back
we have Queen to h3 check King to d8 and
it was in this position our move 63 that
the players agreed to a draw yeah a
great game by both of them Carlsen
really created a lot of chances first he
he closed the center then he closed the
King side then twice continues to push
on the Queen side and really playing on
every side of the board and then at that
one moment where he had a chance after
Queen to b6 to find this well exquisite
line we can say that allows him to
outmaneuver the night at the knight pair
with the bishop pair he missed it he
went 4-4 a queen to e2 but what no one
can really blame him
just it's just that lately he's really
gotten people used to him playing always
the the top engine line and now when he
misses it everyone in the chat is always
like oh how did he miss it you know he
he he knows nothing but I mean I mean
you can't expect humans do to always go
for the for the top engine line but
really an impressive line and here he
missed one little thing and it was
enough for Anand to really show his
class and and perform this brilliant
defense that allowed him to grab the
draw and prevent Carlsen from grabbing
yet another full point and I did prepare
a few photos here there we have a nice
photo after the game it's after the game
finished they are just you know
analyzing you know saying which lines
they've shown and after the game in an
interview Anand actually said that he
thought he saw the line that a lot
cousin to win and that he thought
crossing would play but cousin didn't
didn't support it so there you have it
and also as you will enjoy the standing
so much here are the standings after
round three cross and hence Fiddler's
sharing first place with two and a half
points then we have with two points
Fabiano karana and Vishwanathan Anand
with a point and a half
we have Maximo Sheila Graham and Levon
Aronian with one point Paco Vallejo a
girl Meyer and ARCA denied each and in
last place with 0 points but with
exquisite games so far and with a deadly
stare of course a Vincent Kaymer the
star of the show so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it once again sorry for
not showing it yesterday I was
really too tired I would like to thank
of incenter quintanilla Peter East Simon
Johansen Lucas Williams and team
Moriarty for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous video here I think all
for watching and I will see you soon
with run for of the cockatrice classic
do check out the links in the
description below impressions from round
three and an excellent interview with
Fabiana Carmona after his game with
Vincent camera yesterday so yeah that's
it I will see you soon have an excellent
rest of your day